dr fauci feels liberated
dr fauci was just giving a press
conference
uh because now you know he worked for
reagan then he worked for
bush then clinton then bush then obama
then trump now he's working for joe
biden presidents come and go
dr fauci remains and he was asked about
the differences in working for biden and
working for trump
he couldn't be happier you've joked a
couple times
today already about the difference in
that you feel and being kind of the
spokesperson for this issue
in this administration versus the
previous one can you talk a little bit
about
about how you feel uh kind of
released from from what you had been
doing for the last year
yeah but you said i was joking about it
i was very serious
about it i wasn't joking no actually
i mean i mean obviously i don't want to
be going back
you know over history but it was very
clear that there were things that were
said
uh be it regarding things like
hydroxychloroquine and other things like
that
that really was an uncomfortable because
they were not based on scientific fact
i can tell you i i take no pleasure at
all
in being in a situation of contradicting
the president so it was really something
that you didn't feel that you could
actually say something and there
wouldn't be any repercussions about it
the idea
that you can get up here and talk about
what
you know what the evidence what the
science is
and know that's it let the science speak
it is somewhat of a liberating feeling
it's a liberating feeling and as dr
fauci feels more and more liberated as
dr fauci
has more and more liberty our liberties
seem to shrink seem to decay seem almost
to disappear
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from alex
morris who says
if a conservative speaks in a forest and
no one is around to hear them
censor them anyway that's true this is
the new opinion of the left
it used to be if conservatives are
around
twitter if they're around youtube if
they're around your platform with lots
of liberals on it then you should censor
them
but ever since they booted parlor from
the internet it says
yeah send conservatives out into the
middle of nowhere and then censor them
anyway
we're going to have a whole lot more of
that coming
and i know it makes people feel
uncomfortable if you want to feel really
comfortable you got to check out
buttercloth buttercloth is the most
comfortable dress shirt you will ever
wear
that is not hyperbole in any way i
didn't believe it until i tried it
you're not going to believe it until you
try it and you have to try it
buttercloth is not stiff and scratchy at
all like typical men's dress shirts
it feels like you are wearing your
favorite softest t-shirt it feels it
almost feels like you're wearing pajamas
but it looks really sleek like a dress
shirt
there's this revolutionary fabric with
long fiber cotton and six-way stretch
i figured it was some crazy synthetic
thing it's not it's just really
really amazing cotton it's breathable
keeps you warm in winter and cool in
summer they even have one shirt
where it's got little mint fibers in it
so you put it on even after you've worn
it many many times
and it cools your skin down it's
unbelievable they got the attention of
abc's hit show
shark tank they got a quarter million
dollar investment in it and they should
have gotten a bigger investment frankly
you should invest in butter cloth uh
they're offering right now 20
off your first purchase to our listeners
go to buttercloth.com
knowles receive 20 off your first full
price order that is buttercloth.com
slash knowles kowles you know how much i
love butter cloth
really really tremendous clothing
dr fauci feels so liberated that he can
finally discuss the science
without having to say things that are
not based in scientific fact
like for instance you remember at the
start of the pandemic
when dr fauci came out and said do not
wear masks masks don't work
masks will not stop the spread of a
virus maybe they'll sort of make you
feel good
but they won't actually do anything to
stop the spread you remember when he
said that
and then weeks later completely
contradicted himself
and said now you have to wear masks you
should wear masks all the time
then you remember weeks after that as he
was still discussing how much you have
to wear masks
and even wore a mask in the middle of an
empty baseball stadium right on there
and he tried to dribble a pitch to the
catcher then he went back to his seat
what did he do sitting right next to his
friends
takes his mask off you remember that i'm
so glad
that now he doesn't feel that he has to
contradict scientific fact
and when he was asked about this by the
way do you know what his excuse was
this blatant contradiction he said well
look at the time i said don't wear masks
we wanted to save the masks for the
healthcare workers
so we didn't want all the plebes buying
it you know we didn't want all you
proles
buying buying up all the masks then the
important elites can't get him
so yeah i lied to you i told you you
shouldn't wear the masks at
all and then when we found out we had
enough masks for the healthcare workers
i told you something different but you
should believe me now even though i'm
telling you at this very second that i
lied to you at the start of the pandemic
believe me now scientific fact what was
missed i think by a lot of people in
that admission that fouchy made
regarding healthcare workers and the
reason why he discouraged the masks
and encouraged the masks and the reason
why he's actually said this even
on possible death rates or survival
rates all these sorts of things
he said he said he was
hoping that if he gave out a certain
number that could maybe
push the conversation in another
direction he's not just reading
the scientific data such as it is he's
he's
an activist he's trying to push society
in one direction or the other
fair enough that's part of his job as a
social scientist
but that's not science in the way that
we're talking about it right
in the way that fouchy's joking about it
at the press briefing he's saying
i just want to look i'm just about the
facts i don't have a political ideology
no you do
you do if you're if you're saying that
you're going to lie to the public
so that certain people can get something
and certain people won't buy it all up
that's a political consideration
and that's what all of this is about
fauci's liberation
is a liberation for the technocracy
fauci's liberation is a liberation for
the blob
the unaccountable bureaucrats who we do
not elect
who presidents come and go and they stay
there forever
and they really are liberated under
biden because biden is nobody biden is
absolutely nothing if you unbuttoned his
suit jacket and unbuttoned his shirt you
could stick your hand all the way
through there's nothing but
air in there he is nothing but a vessel
for that
blob for that liberal establishment most
of which
is beyond the scope of democratic
politics most
of which is the major multinational
corporate interest
much of which is the big technology
interest that controls the flow of
information in the public square
most of which is the administrative
state that has very little connection
to democratic politics that is a
liberation
but that liberation is directly contrary
to our liberties the liberties that we
the people
have enjoyed and enjoyed less and less
with each passing breath
that dr fauci takes to
regurgitate his ridiculous edicts in
public
the greatest the greatest regret i would
say that i have from the trump
administration
is that trump did not get out there on
day three
and fire fouchy and banish him to a far
off island
he is a power mad liar he is
so deceitful he is utterly ignorant
of political philosophy he's very good
at practical politics but he's
he's either ignorant or intentionally
deceitful
about the nature of the american
constitutional order and political
philosophy and he's a great danger to
the country
and now that dude is liberated one thing
he's very happy to announce dr fauci
is that the united states is going to be
rejoining the world health organization
you remember the
the u.s pulled out of the w.h.o because
the who is a puppet organization for the
chinese communist party and the who
permitted china to have this virus
fester in their country
they totally carried water for china
they totally lobbied for chinese
interests
even as the virus was beginning to
spread and the head of the
of the who was was picked by the ccp
and dr fauci so pleased to announce now
that that mean old trump is gone
now we're getting back to business as
usual for the liberal blob
we're going to rejoin the w.h.o am
honored
to announce that the united states
will remain a member of the world health
organization
yesterday president biden signed the
letters retracting
the previous administration's
announcement to withdraw
from the organization and those letters
have been transmitted to the secretary
general
of the united nations and to you
dr tedros my dear friend
in addition to retracting the
notification
of withdrawal and retaining membership
in the who the united states
will cease the drawdown of united states
staff
seconded to the who
and will resume regular engagement
of u.s government personnel with the who
both directly and through our who
collaborating centers dr
ted ross my dear friend dr tedros dr
tedros who's the head of the who
was hand-picked to lead that
organization by the chinese communist
party
as part of a broader chinese strategy to
take over these
multinational international institutions
many of which fall under the umbrella of
the united nations
which should be bulldozed and turned
into the donald trump presidential
library and casino
beautiful waterfront property i think it
would be a wonderful
wonderful way to celebrate the first
term of trump's presidency
he's a young man compared to joe biden
there's a lot of opportunity in the
future
tedros w.h.o
many of these these multinational
institutions not just the
non-governmental ones but the corporate
ones do
fall under this liberal blob and they
are so happy
these guys are back in power you want to
see how creepy this is
there's a there's a clip going around
you've maybe you've heard about the
conspiracy theory of the great reset
or you know the idea that that a lot of
liberal people are going to
exploit the coronavirus issue to
reset society rework the economy rework
various political orders so radical
crazy conspiracy i have no idea
where they would have gotten this idea
from it's a very pertinent question
to ask how do we build that better to
build back better or whatever
we have a chance to reset the clock and
build back
better than before to build back better
than before
remember the the terrible damage of
covid as we try to build back
from this uh global pandemic joe biden
calls it build back better
build back better building back better
to do things differently to build back
better we're going to build it back
better
and build it back better my plan to
build back better uh start
taking all the problems that have been
created in education and mental health
and start to
to build back in a positive way i have
launched
a booklet called build back better
britain after coronavirus
it's about building this country back
better growing conspiracy following it
it is called the great reset
unprecedented opportunity
to rethink and reset the ways in which
we live
that clip could go on for several more
minutes okay
so i i understand that some people get
kooky with their
their theories about these kind of
cabals of evil elites ruling the world
i don't think you need any kind of
conspiracy theory
people in public the liberal elite in
public are coming out saying yes we're
going to use this as an opportunity
to rework the economy to rework society
to rework the political order there's no
question about that there's obviously
cooperation going on not just among the
liberal blob in the united states
but around the world certainly certainly
a time
where we want to feel safe and secure
not
just in our persons but in our personal
data that's why you got to check out
lifelock a new tactic for stealing your
credit card and personal information has
recently been discovered this new web
skimming attack or e-skimming injects
malicious code into a compromised
ecommerce website's checkout process
that pulls your order information to
display it on a fake checkout page
that steals your information it is
important to understand how cyber crime
and identity theft are affecting our
lives every day
we put our information at risk on the
internet you could miss
certain identity threats by just
monitoring your credit which is why
there's lifelock lifelock is a leader in
identity theft protection it is so easy
i i didn't used to think this either i
used to think
oh well they're not going after my
information they are and it's very easy
to get no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses
lifelock can see threats that you might
miss on your own join now and save up to
25 percent off your first year at
lifelock.com
slash knowles canada l-e-s that is
lifelock.com
knowles can it w-l-e-s for 25
off use lifelock do not go on the
internet without
lifelock this
idea of building back better this
idea of some people are calling it the
great reset
i don't really use that term because it
sounds conspiratorial
and it sounds like secret and nefarious
it certainly is nefarious but it's all
out in public
you have plenty of of these liberal
elites
some of the elected politicians and many
unelected people describing this
and the way that one builds back better
or the way the one resets society is
is not really done through democratic
politics
in a way it is you'll some of these
people are elected but mostly how this
will be done
is at the administrative level or at the
corporate level
also beyond the realm of of democratic
accountability
when you put people out of work for nine
months ten months it's more than that
now i guess i guess we're coming up on a
year aren't we
when you put people out of work for that
long you
you make them much more vulnerable to
these sort of plans you you
gin up society you encourage the sort of
riots that we saw all year long
you clamp down on political rights now
you can't you can't go to church
still in many places you could always go
buy a dime bag of pot in california
you could always go to those
essential services but you couldn't go
to church
and the excuse for this was public
health well who runs the public health
it's this bureaucracy it's this
doctor dictatorship it's dr fauci
liberated and where
where do our liberties go with that
liberation
very very creepy there is one set of
rules
for the people there is one set of rules
for the liberal elite
we talked about this a lot yesterday we
mentioned
yesterday how joe biden
issued a mask mandate he said on federal
lands you must
always wear a mask no exceptions at all
times
he then hours later goes to the lincoln
memorial
to participate in this ritual he goes it
brings his entire family well not the
not the grandchildren that he refuses to
acknowledge but he brought the family
that he
will acknowledge uh he brings them to
the lincoln memorial
and they're just cello playing and it's
all very beautiful they're not wearing
masks none of them were wearing masks
hours after he mandated that all the
rest of us wear masks at these very
places
jen saki the press secretary now for
biden
was asked a question about this
yesterday they said you know isn't that
a kind of a
mixed message that we're getting we're
told you everyone has to wear masks but
then
biden and his entire family won't wear
masks themselves
saki had a weak answer why weren't
president biden and all members of the
biden family masked
at all times on federal lands last night
if he signed
an executive order that mandates masks
on federal
lands at all times at the inaugural
memorial yes i i think steve he was
celebrating uh an evening of a historic
day in our country and certainly he
signed the mask mandate because
it's a way to send a message to the
american public about
the importance of uh wearing masks how
it can save tens of thousands of lives
we take a number of covered precautions
as you know here in terms of
testing social distancing mass squaring
ourselves
as as we do every single day but i don't
know that i have more for you on it than
that
oh man first the first take that i have
on this
is not even having to do the substance
which we'll get to in a second my first
take is
this woman is really bad at her job i
know that the press are going to say
she's wonderful and brave and stunning
and glorious and everything
kaylee mcenany whether you like her or
not you should like her she's just
tremendous but
even if you don't like her you have to
acknowledge she was very good at her job
she was very very good she was always so
prepared she had killer answers she had
mic drop moments
sarah sanders incredibly good at her job
okay the trump press secretaries did a
great job
this woman fumbling around well uh he
he didn't wear the mask because he
wanted to send a message oh he sent a
message
oh honey he sent a message it wasn't the
message that you
seem to think he's sending it wasn't the
message that the masks are really
important
and we've all got to wear them the
message he sent was there's going to be
one set of rules for you
the peasants and there's going to be one
set of rules for me and my family and
that's been true
for the biden family for many years
if anybody did what the biden family did
in ukraine
in china selling political influence
for millions and millions of dollars
they would be in orange jumpsuits
not the biden family not the liberal
elite not the liberal establishment
it is all about a new hierarchy it's all
about a new
caste system it's all about one set of
rules for the
and one set of rules for me
you're going to see this increase there
was a video yesterday posted by biden to
youtube
titled president biden swears in day one
presidential appointees in a virtual
ceremony
this was posted on january 20th day he
was inaugurated
the comments were turned off
now i think they've since been turned
back on and
it and we've now learned why they were
turned off in the first place this thing
was ratioed
as can be i think got about 5 000 likes
and 25 000 dislikes not a good ratio
and one does not even want to look at
the comments
this is what you're going to see we
talked about it yesterday in the name of
democracy
we're going to see behavior that is very
anti-democratic
we're going to see fouchy liberated
we're already seeing
that happen and it's a very ugly thing
the reason they do this is because they
know that if they open up
their agenda to democratic
accountability they'll lose
i'm even i'm going to put the election
aside for a second there are
many questions that one may have about
about the election and elections moving
forward
i'm going to put that aside for a second
if you put out there if you said i'll
give an example that's very
popular if you said hey i want a
referendum
on whether or not to let grown men into
the girls changing room at the public
pool
how do you think that would do at a fair
open ballot
i think probably it would be like 90 to
10
against that measure right i there's no
way that would pass
and yet the left with their vessel
joe biden are pushing for that actually
that specific example they've already
pushed for through an executive order
joe biden this is one of his first acts
as president don't tell me he's going to
be moderate he won't
he signs this order that reads in part
quote
every person should be treated with
respect and dignity and should be able
to live without fear no matter who they
are or whom they love
blah blah blah obviously just nothing
nothing platitude platitude
give me the meat what does this mean
children should be able to learn without
worrying about whether they will be
denied
access to the restroom the locker room
or school sports
hold up as far as i know no child
is told he can't use the bathroom or he
can't play sports
or he can't go to the locker room i
don't see any example of that anywhere
in the country
unless joe biden is using a euphemism
here is he saying that
it's not that children are denied access
to play sports it's that little boys are
denied access to play girl sports
that's what he's saying adults should be
able to learn to earn a living and
pursue a vocation knowing
that they will not be fired demoted or
mistreated because of whom
they go home to or because how they
dress does not conform
to sex-based stereotypes people should
be able to access healthcare and secure
a roof over their heads without being
subjected to sex discrimination
all persons should receive equal
treatment under the law no matter their
gender identity or sexual orientation
and there it is there it is in one fell
swoop joe biden eliminated through
executive order
girls sports girls bathrooms
girls changing rooms this pervert and
you know i've i've held off on calling
him a pervert even when we were all
making fun of the hair sniffing and all
that stuff
i held off i felt it was kind of a cheap
political shot he's he's a back slapper
not a pervert
this executive order is perverted it's
sick it's deranged
this sicko on his first day in office
second day in office makes it a top
priority to let grown men
into the little girls changing room sick
sick stuff
could only ever happen through executive
order
you know joe biden has been right a
couple of times
i would say at at most a couple of times
broken clocks are right a couple of
times a day
if you want a clock that works though
you got to check out vincero
vincero watches oh man are they great i
love it because it reminds me of the
italian word vincero which is like the
in the song nesundorma you know
i will win these watches they're super
cool they look fabulous
very very stylish a little a little more
intricate maybe than some other watches
on the market
they look tremendous and the price is
really really really reasonable finding
a watch that is
stylish bold and built to last
can cost a pretty penny vincero watches
are changing that they believe that you
deserve to look good no matter
your budget you deserve better than
settling for something underwhelming
with the new year they are now offering
a five-year warranty and a 365-day
return policy
these are some of the best promises in
the business you're not going to want to
return it when you put it on you will
know
that you got more than you paid for this
is the best value for your money
guaranteed it's a little more of an
intricate design
they look really really good they've got
twenty thousand five star reviews
it's uh it's really high quality stuff i
i also love
that it's it's vincero you know like
vincero like the last line of nissan
dorman you know like i will win i will
conquer
you can conquer the time your schedule
and fashion
this deal is too good to pass up get the
year started right go to v-i-n-c-e-r-o
watches
dot com forward slash knowles to get 15
percent
off auto applied at checkout if you use
that link
do not pay full price on these beautiful
timepieces head on over to
vincerowatches.com knowles for 15
off right now go get them i just i just
ordered a new one i just ordered the
bellwether i think it looks
super sleek and stylish go check out
vincero watches
now that biden is showing his radicalism
we are seeing pushback already with one
congressman representative marjorie
taylor green
filing articles of impeachment against
joe biden
already he what he's two days into his
presidency now
she's already filed articles of
impeachment i think it's absolutely
hilarious
here is her reasoning just filed
articles of impeachment on president joe
biden
we'll see how this goes now i say that's
her reasoning because
that's basically all impeachment is
going to mean from now on
i i think the legal argument has
something to do with
the massive evidence of his corruption
in china which was suppressed by the big
tech companies
before the election the hunter biden
scandal that was completely shut down
you couldn't even message the article
because they wanted to throw the
election for
for joe biden and then only after it
didn't matter anymore did they
finally reopen that there was a study
that came out from
the media research center that i think
was something like 14 percent of biden
voters could have changed their vote had
they known about that scandal
so that's i guess ostensibly the legal
basis but that's not really
the the basis for impeachment is purely
political in this case
which is you're going to impeach my guy
multiple times well i'm going to impeach
your guy and that's
probably the way politics is going to
start working
probably there i mean they're still
impeaching
the past the previous president so there
will there will be a
senate impeachment trial for donald
trump who cannot be impeached because
he's no longer in office
and i know that there are some people
who think this is an open constitutional
question it's constitutionally absurd
that the president can be convicted
impeached and convicted
after he has left office it cannot
happen
and if it does happen it's a it's a
constitutional absurdity and outrage
so now the republicans are going to file
impeachment against biden
fine by me totally fine by me
why is it because i think impeachment
should be used this way
no i don't think impeachment should be
used this way i think it's a wrong way
to use impeachment
but impeachment is used this way and i
don't think that we're going to restore
a more dignified kind of politics by
unilaterally disarming i think that's
what we've done for a very long time and
it and it didn't work out very well
we kind of tried this already you know
barack obama committed
impeachable offenses notably in his
irs scandal uh notable fast furious
would be another example but the irs was
really bad doj he uh spied on
his political rivals and tried to
undermine their campaigns if we're
allowed to now impeach and convict
presidents after they've left office
let's do that let's impeach obama
but we tried okay i don't i don't want
to hear this is what we're going to hear
they're going to say republicans started
all of this because in the 90s they
impeached bill clinton over
some eccentric activities in the oval
office private matter
well that's not true he was impeached
for perjury but even putting that aside
okay let's say let's say the clinton
impeachment was ill-advised let's say it
was political even
okay or partisan rather rather than
having a legal basis
fine we did not impeach
barack obama when we could have john
boehner and mitch mcconnell refused to
do it
did that buy us goodwill did that
restore us to a dignified kind of
politics
no they impeached trump they actually
did exactly what marge retailer green
did
everyone remembers well the current
impeachment and they remember the the
impeachment a year ago people forget the
articles of impeachment filed in 2017.
representative al green interestingly it
was another representative green
who first proposed impeaching trump in
2017.
right at the beginning of his presidency
why well green's argument was
if we don't impeach trump he might get
reelected that's the argument for
impeaching him now they're saying if we
don't
impeach trump and convict him in the
senate he might run for office again and
get reelected
does that sound like people who think
that they have
the majority of americans on their side
does that sound like people who think
that democracy is going to triumph
for them does that sound like people who
believe their views are really
really popular i don't think so i think
it sounds like people who
who know that the only way that they're
going to win is through
chicanery through irregularity i'll
leave it at that
you know mitch mcconnell
wants to delay this impeachment trial
mitch mcconnell so the conviction
already happened
mitch mcconnell wants to delay the
impeachment until mid-february
so according to mcconnell's timeline the
impeachment article would be read before
the senate on january 28th
then trump would have to respond by
february 4th even though he's out of
office
then he would have another week until
february 11th at the latest to submit a
pre-trial brief
then the house would be required to
submit a pre-trial brief by february 4th
also then a rebuttal pre-trial brief
would
happen february 13th then you get the
impeachment trial
very strange obviously we've never been
in a situation like this before
and even this whole idea of the
impeachment i mean
we were saying it traces back to bill
clinton it doesn't it actually goes back
to
to richard nixon you know
watergate and you know all those things
that are worse than watergate today
everything is worse than watergate today
but it really did begin the democrats
did start all of this with nixon
and it was ridiculous because nixon's
offenses were nothing compared to what
had been done by his predecessors who
were democrats
but they really wanted to oust him
because he was an effective and pretty
tough president
we've we've never done this we've never
removed a president from office through
impeachment and and we've certainly
never removed a president
for from office after he left office
through imp that's not even how
impeachment works
but so mcconnell's trying to push it off
and push it off and push it off i don't
think this is about helping trump
i think this is about gaining leverage
okay i think this is about saying look
democrats you're gonna have this big
ambitious agenda
and i right now could may i could give
you your conviction i could keep trump
out of running for office again or maybe
i couldn't maybe i could stand in the
way what do you want what do you want to
do i think
mitch mcconnell's a wheeler and dealer i
don't think he has any special love for
trump
and i think they're going to drag this
out as leverage which one can expect
but if they do convict trump i don't
even know what it means to convict trump
after he's left office
that will make this problem so so much
worse and we're not going to
win that argument through concession
we're not going to win this battle by
playing nice they don't want to play
nice with us
we need to get tougher we need to assert
ourselves we need to stand up
with greater courage you know joe biden
one of the most disgusting aspects of
his presidency and it's already pretty
disgusting
is that he blasphemes his religion he
uses his religion blasphemously to
justify
major major evils such as abortion and
trying to get taxpayers to fund abortion
that sort of thing
and questions of gender and everything
else so the usccb the u.s council of
catholic bishops usually a very weak
organization
they came out under archbishop jose
gomez who i really like actually i think
he's a he's a good guy
he came out and he criticized president
biden and he said you know
this is really bad i must he said all
these nice things about biden
he said i must point out that our new
president has pledged to pursue certain
policies that would advance moral evils
and threaten human life and dignity most
seriously in the areas of abortion but
also
contraception marriage gender and the
liberty of the church now cardinal
supich who some
some people who are very rude have
called cardinal cupcake but i
it's very rude uh cupich and other
corrupt people in the catholic church
have pushed back on this that how dare
you stand up for unborn babies
let let them all die let let biden
pursue his
his murder murderous agenda unimpeded
come on how dare you i love that gomez
stood up here archbishop gomez i wish
that the bishops would stand up even
further joe biden must be excommunicated
this is
he he is in a state of grave mortal sin
ex communication is not just a
punishment
it's something that one does out of
compassion
to right the guy's soul and to write the
souls of
the flock because not just of the grave
sin of supporting abortion but this
grave sin
of scandal which is being incurred but
as long as
we refuse to assert ourselves as long as
we refuse to have courage the worst
elements of society are going to be
liberated and it's going to be much more
difficult to to
bring them back in you know we just
crossed 400 000 subscribers be sure to
check out
rip to the funniest commander in tweets
which are the funniest tweets from
trump's presidency
uh we we put this out there as a sort of
in memoriam to
trump's twitter account not even just
the administration but the tweets
they're really
really tremendous last night i walked in
to sweet little lisa because i was
reading through some of trump's tweets
on diet coke
and one of them i loved when he was
attacking diet coke
he went out and he said you know
coca-cola is very angry with me because
of my comments on diet coke
that's okay i'll still keep drinking
that garbage
that is such a brilliant so complex
so bizarre and there were some so many
wonderful tweets like that so go check
it out go check out daily wire's first
movie run hide fight
you know we're in the entertainment game
now we got our first movie out the
critics hate it and the audience loves
it
it's got it's got like a two percent
critics on rotten tomatoes and it's got
like a 98
uh audience score because the movie's
not politically correct and it's not you
know really nice and liberal and
everything
so go check it out uh you can get 25 off
if you use promo code rhf
to become a daily wire member that is
rhf for 25 off
we will be right back with the mailbag
all right first question from keith dear
michael in several of your shows you've
said reality will
always reassert itself our culture and
politics seem to careen further left for
the next four years
under biden's administration in your
opinion what will be the first
ways or areas in which reality will
begin to reassert itself against the
insanity of the left
and how far will our country and culture
have to sink before that happens well
we are seeing it reassert itself in one
way and it's this issue we were just
talking about today
the girls bathrooms thing really seems
to be
uh an important issue and a wedge issue
when i say a wedge issue i mean it
drives a wedge
between our political opponents you've
got the left brought let's say you on
the left you've got feminists
and you've got these gender ideologues
right these kind of
the transgenderists
they're leftists right feminists
included they're they're leftists we're
conservatives
but this issue of the transgender
bathrooms splits the left it drives a
wedge in between them between the
feminists who say wait a second girls
ought to be able to have sports
girls ought to be able to change in
privacy girls ought to be able to have
their own bathrooms
this is what we've been fighting for for
decades and the transgenderists
who say there's no such thing as girls
honey you know
men can define femininity and actually
being a woman is nothing more than
slapping on some lipstick and a pair of
stilettos
and then the feminists saying what how
dare you you can't reduce femininity to
that and then they sort of
duke it out and you see this in the
battles between jk rowling
famously and other leftists jk rowling
is what you'd call a trans-exclusive
radical feminist she's not there's
nothing radical
about her view on gender she's saying
men and women are different right
there's
nothing radical at all about that the
radical view
is that men and women are not different
so i do think that's one way in which
reality will reassert itself
it is important to recall though that uh
the conservative consolation is reality
eventually reasserts itself but it can
take a while
it can take a long time french
revolution took a long time
okay uh lots of uh lots of bad things
can happen
in the meantime there's something i
notice you know conservatives often talk
about and i'll talk about it on the show
too
the kind of progressive utopian view of
politics that the arc of history bends
toward justice
and we kind of make fun of that and it's
right to make fun of that because the
view is preposterous
however conservatives have have a
an analogous view right christians have
a view we we think that
history will end up in justice it's just
that it'll get a lot worse before then
in the end times and then we're go and
then we'll have the second coming of
christ
and we'll have this wonderful new heaven
and new earth right
progressivism is just in so many ways an
aping
of christianity an inversion of
christianity it's uh we've talked about
this many times on the show
political correctness is an
anti-standard
it's a new speech code to overthrow the
old moral codes and
uh so you're seeing these analogous
sorts of things
i i but when we say reality research
itself in the end we're making a similar
claim to
you know the arc of history bends toward
justice but even for the progressives
when they say the arc of history bends
toward justice
well it might take a long time right and
they talk about that as well so i think
it is important
to recognize the similarities between
our views the difference is
that theirs is a kind of mirror image
you know
inversion of the of the true principle
and the true moral order from matthew
future press secretary knowles
will daily wire hire a white house
reporter for the daily wire to ask the
challenging questions of the biden
administration you know
to compete with mainstream media and
actually get real reporting i recommend
kaylee mcenany
yeah she would be pretty great oh my
gosh could you imagine if we sent kaylee
in
as the white house reporter asking
questions of jen saki who
appears to have some whistling going on
between the years just not quite
up to the job in the way that her
predecessors in the trump administration
were that'd be great i can't imagine
biden would ever let us in
i just don't see that happening
conservatives always
take questions from these leftist
reporters but but the left does not
usually take questions of right-wing
reporters very very few
one one exception might be peter ducey
peter ducey from fox news actually does
very good work and has needled to joe
biden for a long time but that's it you
know they'll let the one
maybe one outlet out which isn't even
all that conservative
these days uh uh they i don't think they
would let someone who's
strongly conservative really in into the
room so sadly i don't think i think
we're gonna get a whole lot more
questions of so
what color drapes does joe want in the
oval office wow what a fascinating
question
from daniel michael i've noticed that
you like to use the phrase the
protestant revolution
to describe what they call the
reformation but a revolution implies
the overthrow of a whole system such as
the french or russian revolutions
as it is inaccurate to term the american
separation from britain a revolution
right because it didn't overthrow great
britain likewise it seems inaccurate to
call the separation of the protestants
from the roman church a revolution
the church has not been overthrown but a
schism has occurred
a roman catholic friend of mine calls it
the protestantism
and that seems a more appropriate
description what do you think i agree
with that i think as a matter of
religion and theology uh protestantism
is
is more precise just like you talk about
the great schism
between the east and the west right that
happened thousand years ago
however i still prefer for the purposes
of this show i still prefer the term
protestant revolution because
putting religion aside that certainly
the various protestant denominations
didn't overthrow
the catholic church but as a political
matter they did
as a political matter the protestants
won
the the protestant revel and by the way
i tend to view the protest what is
whether you call it the president i mean
it wasn't a reformation in the sense
that it didn't
reform the church it just created
another church so it's i i really don't
use the term reformation but whether you
want to call it a system or a revolution
or whatever
as a political matter the protestants
won you know what happened out of the
protestant revolution
was you had all of these kind of wars of
religion you had the 30 years war
and then the end of the 30 years war was
the peace of westphalia which in 1648
established our system of nation states
the world order as we know it today
was a a product directly of the
protestant revolution you would not have
this system of nation-states without it
and so
as a result i do consider that to be a
revolution and i don't who knows what
the next world order will be you know
we're always
we always hear this term the new world
order a one-world government kind of
going back to an empire
model but not a christian empire it's
like some kind of weird secular
atheist liberal empire whatever
i just mean until there is a another
world order
uh you know that that revolution defines
our political world and so i i do prefer
that term but i think precisely as a as
a religious matter yes it is it is a
system
from mitchell dear mr knowles i am a 16
year old writing from
saint paul minnesota believe it or not
there are conservatives there
i was recently having a discussion with
a friend and he proposed getting rid of
the two-party system
because it seemed to result in the two
sides hating each other however we
struggled to find a system to replace it
would you recommend getting rid of the
two-party system if so what would you
recommend replacing it with no i would
not get rid of it i'm a great defender
of the two-party system
the two-party system is good if you have
20 different parties like they have in
many european countries
you have usually chaos and governments
collapsing
and sometimes you have uh radical
parties
empowered because more mainstream
parties kind of
split the more mainstream vote and the
radicals can kind of get in there
sometimes
so i don't like that at all if if you're
saying we need to get rid of party
politics
altogether that's just not going to
happen we've had a two-party system in
this country from the very beginning
from we had this washington
administration
which was nonpartisan theoretically but
it was federalist right leaned
federalist and
you then had the federalists and you had
then the
jeffersonian republican democrats right
then you had
other parties that cropped up in the
wake andrew jackson founded the
democratic party
you had the whig party you had abraham
lincoln
sort of found the republican party's
first republican president not the first
republican nominee but you know that
that party is founded in 1854 first
national conventions 1856 first
president of 1860 then you've had those
two parties
ever since then we might have a new
party i'm fine but with that i don't
have any particular love
for the republican party and i certainly
don't have affection for the democratic
party
um but i think we ought ought to
probably keep we will keep the party
system and i hope i hope we keep the
two-party system
for the purposes of having any kind of
moderation or or continuity in our
politics
from brandon dear he who turns the koffe
up to 11.
how palatable would the idea be of
admitting puerto rico as a state
alongside rural parts of northern
california and eastern oregon
to make the state of jefferson a
proposed pacific state states were
admitted as pairs of free enslaved
states to maintain
the balance of political power
previously in our history do you think
the shared desire to grant statehood to
these areas
along with the resulting maintained
balance of political power would make
this idea possible or
even preferable for both sides of the
political aisle could you please explain
to why puerto rico would be a lock for
two democratic senators
with no chance of republicans winning
either seat thanks well
if you just look at the political
preferences of puerto ricans
it's left-wing so i'm not saying that
couldn't change over time but it would
be
it would be a practical matter it would
be a lock
if puerto rico were admitted as a state
i don't like the idea of admitting
puerto rico along with
i don't know the proposed state of
jefferson or something one because
you'd have a lot of trouble if you
started carving up
u.s states separations do not happen
peacefully
separations of political territories
into new political territories
have never happened peacefully as far as
i can tell in this country
or in the world rather very very rarely
um so
you'd you'd be you'd be hard-pressed to
do that i think
i would be as practical matter no state
is going to want to let itself be
cracked up
and what would the purpose be if you're
going to maintain the balance of power
why admit puerto rico is a state
i i don't even see the argument for
admitting puerto rico as a state
if you could present a compelling
argument for why it would be
advantageous to the country
to admit puerto rico as a state then i
guess we could talk about how to do it
and maintain the balance of power but
but even that
that idea of a compromise by the way
reminds us of the 1850s which you're
talking about
in the mid 19th century states were
admitted one slave one free to maintain
the balance of power
that got us a civil war you know that
that was
i i do not look to the 1850s as my
lodestar when i'm trying to craft
politics and i fear that we're in a
situation that has some
parallels to the 1850s and if you were
to get into a situation where you're now
admitting
one democratic state one republican
state and you're banking on those states
remaining that way
to maintain the balance of power that is
a that is a scary
situation to be in and i don't want to
further provoke civil
strife from ruby michael i want to buy a
bible
and i'm overwhelmed with the number of
options i have done some research and i
narrowed it down to the niv the n-e-t
and the rsv bible do not buy the niv
first thought any word of advice would
be appreciated love your show thanks for
all that you do
yes i would recommend obviously i would
recommend a catholic bible so
uh you know you get the deuteronomical
books it's a little bit longer the
deuterocanonical books are the books
that were taken out
after the protestant revolution but so
you get some extra books get more bang
for your buck in that way and i
i suspect more wisdom um if you're going
to get a catholic bible i would
recommend the rsvce
the revised standard version catholic
edition or better yet the douay rheims
which is one of the best
bible translations ever in history uh if
you don't want to do that if
that's a little too macro snapping for
your speed then i would
recommend getting the esv for
readability is a good protestant bible
and the kjv is the most beautiful i mean
that's just a one of the greatest works
of literature ever
ever produced in the english language um
well i i suppose a little less so for
readability
but uh it's it's still uh you know it's
so so beautiful so maybe if you're gonna
buy a protestant bible i'd buy both of
those esv
and kjv and and i guess same same thing
is true for catholic bible if you're
gonna buy a catholic bible in english
maybe by the rsvce and the douay rheims
sorry that i just spent more of your
money for you but i think it's good to
have both with the
sort of heightened beautiful language
and the readability
from gavin hi michael love the show
in the past you've criticized soccer and
other sports as un-american
and referenced boxing as a superior
alternative as someone who practices and
fights in several combat sports i agree
however i'm also a practicing catholic
and have often heard sports like boxing
deemed immoral
which is why though i practice striking
sports such as boxing
i only compete in grappling competitions
like wrestling what is your opinion on
the morality of training and or
competing in mixed martial arts
is it wrong to watch the ufc thanks
hashtag came for ben stayed for knowles
i don't think it's wrong no i mean you
know i'm coming from a perspective
though where my
my priest is a boxer okay so
he's not professional boxer obviously
but he is he's boxed
uh so i i think it's a it is a beautiful
sport right it is sort of the
the beautiful sport and uh soccer is not
it's not the beautiful sport though that
that is a popular idea
it's just it's kind of soft you know
it's kind of boring
it's foreign just don't like it they're
trying to import it
into america but it should not be
imported we import enough bad ideas and
bad things into america
we should do tough good old american
sports and the more it drives the rest
of the world crazy
the better as far as i'm concerned
that's that to me is the marker of how
you know
that it is a a good sport i don't think
people should go out there and start
shivving each other and killing each
other in the ring
but some good combat i think is
perfectly
in keeping with the great tradition of
sports i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
see you next week
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me
andrew clavin